nos dicen evans leyó un artículo en el
cual se mencionan que el 6 por ciento de
los adolescentes son vegetarianos sin
embargo ella piensa que este porcentaje
es mayor para los estudiantes de su
escuela la cual es grande para probar su
teoría ella tuvo una muestra de la
teoría de 25 estudiantes en su escuela y
encontró que el 20 por ciento eran
vegetarianos tan sólo en este primer
párrafo hay algunas cosas interesantes
nos dicen que el valor real de la
proporción poblacional de adolescentes
que son vegetarianos es del 6% si
confiamos en el artículo ahora bien para
su escuela la hipótesis nula es que esta
proporción de estudiantes que son
vegetarianos es la misma que la
proporción de todos los adolescentes
entonces la hipótesis no la me dicen que
la proporción de su escuela va a ser
igual que la misma que todos los
adolescentes es decir un 6%
también podemos ver que evans está
estableciendo una hipótesis alternativa
y está hipótesis alternativa es que este
porcentaje es mayor para los estudiantes
de su escuela así que su hipótesis
alternativa va a ser que la proporción
de estudiantes vegetarianos de esa
escuela es decir el valor real del
parámetro para su escuela es mayor que
el 6% ahora para ver si rechazas o no la
hipótesis nuland tomas una muestra y fue
justo lo que ella hizo para probar su
teoría ella tomó una muestra aleatoria
de 25 estudiantes en su escuela y
calculó la proporción de la muestra
ahora necesitamos calcular cuál es la
probabilidad de obtener una proporción
muestral que sea mayor o igual a
si esta probabilidad es menor que un
cierto umbral entonces rechazaremos la
hipótesis nula ya esta probabilidad le
vamos a llamar el valor p
el valor p es igual a la probabilidad de
que la proporción de la muestra sea ojo
esto lo está haciendo ella para
estudiantes de su escuela sea mayor o
igual que 20%
suponiendo que la hipótesis nula es
verdadera
por lo que si se supone que el valor
real de la proporción de vegetarianos en
la escuela es del 6% y se toma una
muestra para la cual se obtuvo una
proporción del 20 por ciento cuál es la
probabilidad de obtener un valor de 20%
o mayor para una muestra de 25
estudiantes y hay varias formas de
resolver esto pero aparentemente evans
está usando una simulación para ver qué
tan probable es que una muestra como
ésta ocurre al azar
evans realizó una simulación simula la
toma de 40 muestras de n igual a 25
estudiantes a partir de una gran
población para la cual el 6% de los
estudiantes eran vegetarianos registro
la proporción de vegetarianos en cada
muestra a continuación se presentan las
proporciones muestrales para sus 40
muestras lo que está haciendo con
la simulación es obtener una
aproximación de la distribución muestral
de proporciones suponiendo que la
hipótesis nolan es verdadera y nos dicen
acá abajo eba quiere probar que su
hipótesis es nula la cual es que la
proporción real de estudiantes es igual
al 6% contra su hipótesis alternativa la
cual es que la proporción real de
estudiantes es mayor que el 6% donde
bueno que es la proporción real de
estudiantes vegetarianos en su escuela y
ahora con base en los resultados de la
simulación nos preguntan cuál es el
valor aproximado de la prueba y bueno
también nos dicen que notemos que el
resultado de la muestra fue de 20% lo
cual ya sabemos está justo aquí bien si
suponemos que esta es una buena
aproximación de la distribución muestral
de proporciones aquí tenemos 40 valores
muestrales y nos tenemos que preguntar
en cuántas de estas muestras se obtuvo
una proporción muestral mayor o igual al
20%
bueno aquí tenemos al 20% 20 centésimas
y puedes ver que tenemos 3 muestras que
lo cumplen estos de aquí cumplen esta
condición es decir 3 de 40 así que
considerando que esta es una buena
aproximación diríamos que nuestro valor
p va a ser aproximadamente igual a 3 de
40 si la proporción real para la escuela
fuera del 6% si la hipótesis es nula
fuera verdadera entonces aproximadamente
3 de 40 veces esperamos obtener una
muestra en la cual el 20% o más son
vegetarianos
así que 3 sobre 40 es igual
veamos si multiplicamos por 2.5 voy a
multiplicar por 2.5 para que abajo
tengan 100 100 por ciento entonces esto
que es aproximadamente igual a 3 por 2.5
es 7.5 y entonces esto es
aproximadamente igual al 7.5 por ciento
y de hecho esta es una de las opciones
si bajamos la pantalla vemos que
efectivamente aquí tenemos la respuesta
de aproximadamente 7.5 por ciento nos
vemos en el próximo vídeo